[Music]
welcome to our next episode of what's up
Roth thank you for joining us hello
Walter I thank you for joining us and as
usual will you open up up for us with a
word of Prayer Heavenly Father we are
living in such momentous times and
people have questions help us Lord
through your spirit to give proper
guidance according to your word in Jesus
name Amen
we've had a few comments on our previous
videos there's also been a few
questions asked and if it's okay with
you can we discuss some of those
questions today sure first off it seems
that there's some confusion about what
exactly the mark of the beast is and can
you elaborate a little bit for us give
us some clarity yes I can see that in
the questions people are asking about
the the chip and they want to know
whether that is the mark of the beast
now that's a very interesting topic and
I know that in the world out there the
thinking amongst evangelicals is that
the mark of the beast isn't is a chip
that is implanted either in the hand or
on the forehead and basically works like
a bank card with all your details as to
who you are what you are plus more
things of course what your heart rate is
what you're about et cetera et cetera
and is that the mark of the beast now
you have to approach this in a biblical
fashion what is the beast and what is
his mark and the only one that can tell
you what the mark is and what the beast
is is the Bible itself because that's
where we're dealing with these issues
now the Bible tells us who the Beast is
now a beast according to the Bible is a
political system we have that definition
in the Book of Daniel these four beasts
four kings or kingdoms that will arise
so it's a political system a woman in
the Bible is a biblical system so yeah
forever is a church in other words so if
you have a woman riding a beast then you
have a woman controlling the political
system that's basically what it means
yes
so who is the Beast well you have to go
to Revelation chapter 13 and then you
will have a description of the beast and
the beast in Revelation chapter 13 is a
conglomerate of all the beasts of Daniel
chapter 7 where you had the first beast
which was like a lion and the second one
like a bear and the third one like a
leopard and the third the fourth one the
terrible beast with ten horns and then a
little horn appearing etc and in in the
book of Revelation that first beast has
all of those components incorporated in
it and all the Reformers whether it was
Martin Luther or whether it was John
Knox or whether it was Calvin or whether
it was one of the evangelical preachers
later like Wesley or Spurgeon all of
them were agreed given the criteria that
are mentioned that the system described
is that of the Roman Catholic system the
Roman Catholic system is the only church
that qualifies not only as a woman a
church but also as a beast the political
system because it has a it is a
political entity and the hierarchy in
that political entity is the same as you
have with a king and the princes with a
cardinal representing the princes and
the Pope representing the kings so that
system qualifies as a beast system so
it's a political system and this beast
has a mark so if you want to know what
the mark is then the only place to find
out is to ask the Beast what it is is
his mark now God also has a mark in the
by
or a sign or a symbol or a banner and if
you read your Old Testament you will
find that the Sabbath was the sign of
the mark that he is the one who is the
sanctifying force in our lives you'll
read that in the Book of Ezekiel and in
many places in the Bible so the sign of
his authority is the Sabbath for in six
days the Lord made the heavens the earth
to see the springs of water that tells
you that ownership is he's through
creation and because he redeemed you out
of Egypt
that tells you you are he's through
Redemption
now the Roman Catholic Church has
plainly stated in many many places
throughout history that the mark of her
ecclesiastical power is that she is
above the Bible and that she has
transferred the solemnity of the
biblical Sabbath to the first day of the
week and she uses that as a point that
the Council of Trent she made it very
very plain that this is her mark of
ecclesiastical Authority and that
Protestants in spite of what they say
that the Bible is their supreme
authority or actually obedient to Rome
rather than to the scriptures so they
say it is a mark of ecclesiastical power
and this mark will be enforced and many
many writings throughout history and
actions point to this exact same thing
Rome has ever been at war against the
biblical Sabbath which is the mark of
God and has replaced it with her mark of
authority so it's a question of
obedience so now in in the futuristic
thinking this ideology of a mark which
has a moral implication as
who do I acknowledge as the authority in
my life is it the God of the Bible or is
it a church and its hierarchy which one
is the authority in terms of my
salvation and my obedience so if the to
come into into conflict with each other
then that implies a choice so if God
asks me to acknowledge his authority and
the church asks me to acknowledge her
Authority then I have a choice now this
chip it is not improbable that such a
mechanism can be employed but it's not
the mark of the beast because the Beast
is Roman Catholicism and the Beast has
already defined what and what her mark
is so the chip will enable you to do
banking it can be a means let's put it
this way to determine how you do your
banking but it is not the mark of the
beast it is a precursor perhaps to the
issue of not being able to buy or sell
but it is not a moral issue it is not a
moral issue how I approach my bank
account if I use a banking card that is
also a chip it's just in a card and I
don't think God is concerned as to how I
access my bank account now this chip
that they might implant into your hand
is a somewhat more elaborate system
because it entails more than just that
chip on a card but you will remember
that even the chip on the card has been
modified since 9/11 yes because there's
a lot of extra data on that chip where
you live what your place of residence is
many parameters associated with your
identification number or social security
number is associated with that chip so
whether it's on a card or whether it's
in your hand it's still an ax
and it still a means of control yes
so yes it can be in the system in terms
of determining how you buy or sell but
it is not the mark because the mark has
to be identified according to the
biblical criteria it is the mark of the
beast' beef is Catholicism and it has a
mark of authority now if people want to
get more detail on this they will have
to do a serious Bible study so there are
a few lectures on DVD that we've done in
the past the crime of all ages for
example is a lecture on all the
statements by Rome regarding the
transference of the Sabbath as a mark of
our ecclesiastical power yes there's
another lecture that comes to mind which
is two beasts become friends which is a
verse for verse expose of Revelation
chapter 13 where we discuss the two
political systems that will be active in
implementing the mark of the beast at
the same time and remember that the mark
of the beast has to do with worship
because it says in Revelation they
worshipped the first beast now worship
is associated with acknowledging the
authority of so I worship God because I
acknowledge his authority in my life he
is higher than me and I render that
obedience which he requires because he
has the authority if an earthly system
takes that authority and makes it its
own and enforces a law or a mark which
is contrary to God's then I have a
choice to make
yes so what is the meaning of all of
these things there are some other
lectures as well perhaps you can put a
few links in that people can can look at
some of these lectures regarding these
we will do that I'll put the links down
in the comments just another question on
this RFID chip would you say it will be
a model choice if this chip will be
enforced on people or forced on people
to take it that is a good question
was it a moral choice when you received
a bank card no it wasn't a moral choice
so it depends on what the moral issue is
regarding this chip it probably can
encroach on moral issues if your
personal privacy is eroded as a
consequence but as we know even with a
card your private issues can be eroded
so well I think that people will resist
a chip of that nature although many
countries have already - some if well
degree introduced it yes and I don't
think it is a moral issue if it entails
just how you access buying or selling or
because of a cashless society or any one
of those any more than a credit card
would be a moral issue if there are
other issues involved then it might
become a moral issue but if it's just
banking and accessing accounts then I
don't think it is a moral issue although
in in the philosophy out there of course
it becomes a moral issue but then the
bank account and the accessing of the
bank account becomes the moral
denominator rather than the Word of God
yes I see the same also on another
question that we had in the comments
before like we used in one of the
episodes the Apple computers can you
ELISA was there a comment you told me
about a comment that yes why were we
using Apple computers well you know we
are living in the world
but that doesn't mean that we should be
of the world now who controls the
industries of the world it is the mega
corporations and who controls the mega
corporations while according to the
scripture Babylon controls the mega
corporations so there is a connection
between the religious and the economic
world and we've had many lectures in the
past on that issue but you know people
would have to go through the entire
total onslaught series to pick up those
connections but maybe they have time now
are they after I'm sure I will put that
also in the comments below
the total onslaught series is a very old
series but in a sense it is timeless
because the the issues remain exactly
the same
I might have three more hairs then I had
then I have now when I met that series
but it might be one to watch great yeah
the players might also be in that you
mentioned they already replaced with new
ones but the systems still stay the same
so regarding the Apple computers let's
have a look at any issue if you want to
be part of this world mega economic
structure then you have to be part of
that system and basically that cons that
system according to the scripture is not
controlled by God but by other forces
these o Taric forces so whether I Drive
a mock motor vehicle with esoteric signs
on it whether I tank gas at the fuel
station all of them are involved in
these issues for example if you take
some of the petroleum companies they had
interesting symbols and they've changed
over the years as they've modified but
they still have esoteric connotations I
mean one of the big companies at one
stage had Pegasus the flying horse the
god of death as as their symbol I would
want
put the god of death as their symbol
right so my philosophy is simply this I
am in the world and I have to make use
of the systems in the world but I don't
have to be roped into the esoteric or
philosophies of those systems so can I
can I Drive a car that belongs to a
worldly system in order to do the Lord's
work difference of course I can can I
use a computer in order to do the Lord's
work I could also use it for ignoble
means or reasons and there are plenty of
that is available but it is a moral
choice whether I will use this product
for noble purposes or ignoble purposes
and as long as I use it for noble
purposes then I can use it put it
bluntly the devil's equipment and the
devil's money - for them further the
Lord's work I mean thank you
and then there's also some confusion
about the little time of trouble and the
big time of trouble can you maybe
explain to us the difference okay
it is a progressive issue now the little
time of trouble is a time period before
the implementation of the mark of the
beast so in other words turmoil in the
world will increase natural disasters
will become very prominent basically you
can go through the list of Matthew 24
and see what the issues will be at the
end of time there will be many messiahs
and even today there are some issues
that the Messiah is about to reveal
himself and there's great excitement but
jesus said you know when you hear is in
the inner room when you hear is in the
desert don't go there because as the
Lightning is
from the east to the west so will the
coming of the Son of Man be so we have
this period of time of great turmoil and
that is called the little time of
trouble when you're when your personal
freedoms will be restricted and
eventually the act the nation's become
angry and there's more and more of a
clamor for morality the world is going
to pot they will say morality has gone
out of the window and we have all of
these turmoils and these calamities and
maybe they'll even say these viruses
because people have left god this
automatically that will lead people to
start introducing religious legislation
now if you take the Noahide laws that we
talked about for example they have a
religious connotation because you have
to acknowledge the one god and you may
not blaspheme that god that is a law now
that is a law than that means that at
some stage it must be implemented so
there must be religious laws attached to
those laws and apparently there are a
few hundred laws that are subsections of
those laws that can be implemented now
if you have to acknowledge the one God
then surely you must also have a day of
worship for that one God yes so all of
these calamities and this little time of
trouble where your personal freedoms are
curtailed and we're buying and selling
becomes difficult because of
circumstances which restrict human
movement and human freedom will lead to
the point where people say all of these
things are happening because we have
turned our back upon God we have taken
him out of the school system we've taken
him out of public life we may not even
pray we
sacrifice children to mala etc etc etc
let's get back to God that Intel's
legislation so eventually the little
time of trouble will then culminate in
legal issues and laws which will force
you to adhere to a particular model
issue and once those laws are enacted
which are contrary to God's law but not
necessarily contrary to the laws of the
Beast which we are warned against then
you have a moral choice and once that
moral choice becomes the final issue
then you will have the great time of
trouble and the plagues will start
falling so after those laws are enacted
there is still a short period when
people must be able to make a moral
choice you can't have probation closed
when the laws are made because when the
laws of made people must choose between
God's law and man's law and when they're
in conflict with each other it's a moral
issue it's an it's an issue of worship
yes
brings a thought to me about in the
spirit of prophecy there was a quote and
there's a book the last day events and
chapter ting deals with the little time
of trouble the commencement of that time
of trouble here mentioned does not refer
to the time when the plague shall begin
to be poured out but to a short period
just before they are poured out while
Christ is in the sanctuary at that time
while the work of salvation is closing
trouble will be coming on the earth and
the nations will be angry yet health in
check so as to not prevent the work of
the third angel and that is interesting
that is interesting in other words that
legislation which is contrary to God's
law has the mark of the beast has not
yet been implemented so we must be in
the little time of trouble yes
then comes the greater time of trouble
with a great time of trouble after the
implementation after people have made a
decision then the plagues were for and
God promises protection from the plagues
for all who do not accept the mark of
the beast so it's really important that
we understand the mark of the beast
that's why people should perhaps look at
some of these lectures to see what the
Bible has to say about it also in that
time of trouble there that is the time
of Jacob's trouble yes now what was
Jacob's trouble
Jacob had grievously sinned in the way
in which he went about depriving Esau of
his birthright and in in that sense he
was wrestling with God as to whether he
was forgiven or not so in that time when
probation is closed and there is
basically nothing that you can do about
your salvation other than rely on the
one who has redeemed you which is Jesus
Christ that is the time when you go
through Jacob's trouble when you wrestle
with God and say lord have I confessed
my sins have I been forgiven all my sins
have you washed me in the blood of the
Lamb is there any Fault in me which has
prevented you from doing this this is
the the mental anguish and the turmoil
and then faith comes in faith takes hold
of the promises of God and faith does
not let go of them just as Jacob didn't
let go of Jesus with the angel when he
wrestled with him and he said I will not
let you go lest you bless me that is our
anguish we cling in that time to Jesus
and say I will not let you go unless you
bless me and the Bible says he prevailed
with God and so everybody who has
made Jesus he's covering his Clifton The
Rock will prevail because Jesus will
cover them with his righteousness well
so during the little time of trouble
this is still time to look after
yourself
planting aha yes when you come to the
big time of trouble and the plagues fall
then there is nothing that you can do
anymore you're totally reliant upon God
in fact you will have to flee to the
mountains because they will persecute
God's people those who refuse the mark
of the beast and proclaim them as
enemies of the state because now the
world has finally come together and
decided to do one thing in unison and
here's a group that says no it's
contrary to God's law I'm not going to
do it then there will be huge anger and
persecution and then you have to flee to
the mountains and you are totally
reliant upon God then you claim the
promises that your bread and water shall
be sure if necessary God will provide
manna from heaven
or the Ravens will feed you as in the
tongues of Elijah but in the little time
of trouble secure for yourselves land
where you can grow your own vegetables
because the time of buying and selling
will be very acute so that must precede
that time and also it recedes the mark
of the beast so it has nothing to do
with the buying and selling that will be
totally cut off the possibility of
buying and selling through the
legislation of the mark of the beast
which has not yet been implemented yes
then ever just a final question can you
give us clarity on when the time of the
end will commence well if you want to
know about the time of the end you have
to go back to this book again now when
you read in Daniel chapter 12 it tells
you basically when the time of the end
begins and the time of the end according
to Daniel chapter 12
is at the close of the 1260 days which
the Reformers applying the de year
principle referred to as the time of
papal supremacy so once you look at that
period when Rome actually had supremacy
over the world and its dictates or its
moral statutes were the law of the land
which is not the case now was between
538 ad and 1798 in 1798 the political
power of the Roman Catholic Church was
taken away and she lost her beasts
political status and was only a woman at
church but then in 1929 Mussolini gave
back the papal States and she regained
her political power so she again
qualified as a beast and a woman and
since then she has been growing the
Bible calls that the healing of the
wound so the Beast had a mortal wound it
stopped being a political systems' 1798
it received its political status again
in 1929 and eventually the whole world
will follow the morality of that system
in other words papal laws will become
the law of the land so the time of the
end
started at the end of the 1260 days
according to Daniel so that is in 1798
that's when we have moved from that time
period where she had absolute power to
the time when she does not have absolute
power and then we will move back into a
period where she regains that power and
we are there we were we are there the
whole world is running to Rome for moral
directions and once Rome's laws become
legal moral direction then we are at
point when the world will wander after
the beasts that political religious
system so that is the answer according
to Daniel it commenced in 1798 and will
culminate in the time period when she
regains her political power by enforcing
her laws moral values upon the entire
world Thank You Walter for that very
insightful discussion once again can you
please close off for us also with a word
of Prayer certainly Heavenly Father we
all have questions we all want to know
where we stand in the stream of time
time will no longer be an issue because
the Scriptures tell us that after the
2300 days time was no more
in other words prophetic time and so
Lord we can only look at the signs that
fulfill around us to give us an
indication of where we are in the stream
of time and help us to make a good
application of these directives in Jesus
name Amen amen
thank you for the viewers we will see
you next time
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe click here when the bell
appears click and you will receive
notifications to watch the next one
click yeah thank you again and see you
next time